[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS DIBONA: Hi,
I'm Chris DiBona.
I work for Google.
It's a company.
And I look after open source
software for the company, as
much as anyone does.
I like to say that I'm
responsible for a lot of stuff
around open source, as much as--
So you can blame me if
there's something wrong, is
the long and short of it.
But I'm not the only person
who works on open source,
by any measure.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to ask our panelists
to introduce themselves
and to give you a picture
of what a day in their life
is like working
on these projects.
And maybe each of
you can say what's
the favorite thing you see in a
contributor, a new contributor
to a project.
Right?
So, Cassandra,
introduce yourself.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Oh, OK.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: My
name is Cassandra Salisbury.
I am on the open source strategy
team and a program manager
for developer
relations for Golang.
Ooh, a day in my life--
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
It's a lot of emails
but they're primarily around
strategy for growing Golang
and how to work open
source at Google,
as well as how to support
our 1.6 million users for Go.
My favorite thing
about a contributor--
CHRIS DIBONA: How many million?
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
1.6 million.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's up a lot
in the last year.
CHRIS DIBONA: Did you
personally count them?
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: I mean, I
asked for the gophers by color
and demographic, and I
feel like it's close.
Yeah, I feel like it's close.
Maybe we'll get more
exact this year.
But yeah, I think my favorite
thing about a new contributor--
is that you asked?
It's just passion,
and excitement,
and willing to jump in and solve
a problem where they see one.
CHRIS DIBONA: So your favorite
kind of new contributor
is one who just dives in.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Yeah,
it's the most helpful I think,
for me to see
someone take charge.
CHRIS DIBONA: So if I were to
put my finger out and point
at somebody and say, you're
going to connect to Go,
you're going to have them
go to the bug list or the--
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: I'm going
to have them go to GitHub,
or I'm going to have
them join Gopher Slack,
because it's a
really active group.
If they are already into
Go and programming in Go,
then they can go
help the newbies out.
And if they haven't,
then they can
get a lot of their
questions answered there
and figure out where the
best place to start is.
CHRIS DIBONA: And
the Gopher Slack--
I'm sorry, I'm going
to betray my age.
In the old days, on the
#Perl on [INAUDIBLE],,
if somebody were
to ask a question,
often a certain
person would say,
I'm not here to do
your homework, or--
it wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
Or that sounds like
web programming.
You want a different channel.
And it was very unfriendly.
Is the Slack channel friendlier?
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
One of the things
I love about the Go community is
we have a pretty stringent code
of conduct and the Gopher
Slack is very heavily regulated
for welcomeness and inclusivity.
CHRIS DIBONA: That's good.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Yeah.
CHRIS DIBONA: Because
#Perl drove tons of people
into Python's loving arms.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah,
which was fine.
Python's a fine language, right?
[CHUCKLE]
Will.
WILL NORRIS: Yes.
CHRIS DIBONA:
Introduce yourself.
WILL NORRIS: My
name is Will Norris.
I work for Chris.
So I work in our Open
Source Programs office.
I manage two teams that
are primarily focused
on open source compliance.
So we are ultimately responsible
for reviewing all open source
code that comes into
Google and all open source
code that leaves Google,
which turns out to be a lot.
So we review every
package as it comes in--
CHRIS DIBONA: By
hand, line-by-line.
[CHUCKLE]
WILL NORRIS: Yeah, line-by-line,
we review each one.
No.
So our engineering
team-- the only way
that we're able to handle
this is by automating as much
of this as possible.
So we have a lot of tooling
around automatically scanning
for licenses and enforcing
various policies.
We manage-- I don't know.
We're at 140 or so
organizations on GitHub,
which is a lot to manage.
So we've got a lot
of tooling that
uses their API to manage
that, and that kind of stuff.
And then I also work
in a lesser capacity
with our outreach team,
which is responsible
for our own programs
for doing outreach,
Google Summer of
Code, Google Code-in
are both kind of
focused at students
and getting them
involved in open source.
We do that a lot.
And then we also--
we do a lot of sponsorship,
and donations, and memberships,
and things like that.
CHRIS DIBONA: And what
is the TODO Group?
WILL NORRIS: The TODO Group is--
it's an organization-- it's
a group within the Linux
Foundation that is
basically the open source
offices at a lot of
different companies.
So it's kind of like me
or Chris at Facebook,
and Microsoft, and most
of the big companies
that you would think about.
We get together about
quarterly and share a lot
of best practices, some tooling.
Because it turns out
we're all solving
exactly the same problems
in slightly different ways.
And so it's trying to get more
dialogue between companies that
are really trying to
do open source well,
and getting those
companies talking.
CHRIS DIBONA: And like
we asked Cassandra,
when you see a
newcomer coming in,
are there any specific
traits that you say,
oh, that's going to be
a successful developer?
I know it.
Or, they're going
to be a disaster?
I don't know.
I'm not going to a negative.
But, Yeah.
WILL NORRIS: I think
someone who is--
CHRIS DIBONA: Because you--
So Will has to handle the bulk
of the incoming new people
and making sure that
they're properly--
WILL NORRIS: I
think someone who is
willing to take
the time to learn
the community that they're
getting involved with.
We actually just hired a
few engineers on my team
and we use Go for
all of our tooling.
And someone made a comment
about tabs versus spaces.
And I was like, yeah.
You just have to understand
with Go, you use gofmt
and you're done and you
don't think about it.
And just how refreshing
it is to just accept
the community that you're moving
into and not try to fight it.
That tends to work
out really well.
We see the same thing with
CLAs, our legal agreements,
that we have to have for
a variety of reasons.
But I would actually
answer your question
a little bit
differently, which is,
the thing that I love
to see most in newcomers
is when they land that
first patch to a project
and just the sense of completion
and joy that comes from that.
And the Go team did a special
hackathon about a year ago,
where they were really
focusing on getting
people contributing to GoCore.
And it was an amazing
event where they got--
I don't know how many dozens
of new contributors to the core
project.
And it worked out really great.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thank you, Will.
Sarah.
SARAH NOVOTNY:
I'm Sarah Novotny,
and I lead the Open Source
Strategy Group for Google Cloud
Platform.
And my first project here
at Google was to embed--
much like Will described--
learning the Kubernetes
community and engaging
with that community
to help it evolve
from being a company
led project to a
community led project.
Since then, we have grown the
team and the number of projects
that we are embedding people
in, to eight, including Go,
which Cassandra is embedded in.
And we choose these
projects as projects
that are either strategically
important for Google
to open source, so a first
party or outbound project.
And some open source
projects that are
strategically important
to our customers
on Google Cloud Platform.
So things like, Node.js.
Since JavaScript is now, more
common in production than Java,
we needed to be involved in
that language and JavaScript
standards and work like that.
So I also lead the relationship
with the Linux Foundation.
Will mentioned the TODO
Group as part of that.
I sit on the Node.js
Foundation board,
helped found and move Kubernetes
to the Cloud Native Compute
Foundation, and helped the
Open Container Initiative
build its first specifications
for container portability.
But you want to know what I
want to see and a contributor.
CHRIS DIBONA: A new contributor.
SARAH NOVOTNY: A
new contributor.
CHRIS DIBONA: New, shiny.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Brand new.
I think there are a couple
of things in someone coming
into a community, any
community, whether it's
your local nonprofit
Boys and Girls Club,
or an open source
community, it's
understanding the
norms of that community
and not trying to
change it too quickly.
You have to start by
learning the story of how
that community has gotten to
where it is before you say,
you're doing it wrong.
And you spoke about the people
who come into a community
and you're like, ooh,
that's not going to work.
It's those that come in and
say, you need to change this.
You need to do it this way.
You have to earn
your credibility
and earn your opportunity to
make those sorts of changes
in a community.
You really need to start
with helping the community
with the things they need before
you tell them the things you
think they should do.
CHRIS DIBONA: So I want to
make sure that I clarify.
So when I find
someone who I go, oh
gosh, they're coming
on strong, or oh gosh,
I'm not sure that's
going to work out,
those are the ones that
I try to like grab--
SARAH NOVOTNY: Mentor.
CHRIS DIBONA: --like
a mother kitten
and bring them into the
project and say, hey, here's
something you should check out.
And this-- it's right
in line with what
you seem to be good at.
And I try to make them
into the thing that
is best for the project.
SARAH NOVOTNY: It also
speaks to Cassandra's point
about being excited
about and engaged in,
because sometimes people come
into these communities saying,
oh you really need to fix this.
And that's their
excitement showing.
So if you can redirect
that excitement--
It's sort of like
open-source jujitsu--
move that weight and say, here
are three things we need done.
Let's start with these and you
can actually encourage them.
We've, in the
Kubernetes community,
Paris Pittman has spent
a lot of time working
on multiple types of
mentoring in order
to help the new contributor
onboarding experience
and bring people in as
graciously as possible,
and get them working on
things that the project needs
that also gets them the
quick win to the first patch.
And then from there, grow
their influence in the project.
CHRIS DIBONA: So one thing I
want to ask all three of you
is--
so we've been talking
about these big projects,
your TensorFlows,
your Kubernetes--
I was thinking about TensorFlow.
We didn't talk about it yet.
And all the rest.
But one of the things that
people come and ask me
about all the time--
and I know that
you've been asked
this- is getting that first new
contributor, going from this,
oh, well here's a cool
thing we're going to release
and then skipping right to--
it's like step one underpants,
step three profit.
It's like, we all talk
about these communities
and building these
huge ecosystems
but a lot of
projects, they never
get to that first
external contributor.
So what would you do to
help a project get there
or what have you done to
help a project get there?
Maybe it's in a sub
library of Go, or--
Yeah, I'm very curious.
Because I honestly, I
have the hardest time
with this question.
SARAH NOVOTNY: So I'll
jump in because in my team,
we have a number of
people that are working
across a number of
projects and some of them
are at very early stages.
There are projects that
have been recently released.
There are projects that have
been out for eight years.
And so there's this whole
gamut within the lifecycle.
The new projects,
one of the best ways
to get new people involved
and get people excited
is to be an advocate
in that project.
And so that means that it is
easier and more successful
if someone who is already
participating in a project
is super excited
about it and starts
drawing in their friends,
starts drawing in the people
that they know, starts
talking about it on Twitter,
starts just sharing
that excitement.
And those projects start
to take off and start
to build just a reinforcement
of that advocacy,
if you can share
your excitement.
If you're doing this
because it's horrible,
and it just needs to
be fixed, and then
I'm going to open
source it, it's
not likely to take off
as a broader project.
But if you can say why this
is super neat and why you are
so excited about fixing it,
or making this available
to the broader community, or
how it fits in another community
and bootstrap off of that, then
you find like-minded people--
they may be your friends.
There may be other
people trying to solve
the same sort of problem.
And you can invigorate
their interest.
But it does take
some evangelism.
WILL NORRIS: I would say
one of the key things you
can do is to make sure
that your project is ready
and welcoming to newcomers.
And so, this comes down
a lot of times to the way
that you manage your community
and just the documentation.
We find that from projects
that had participated
in the Summer of Code
in previous years,
even if the work that the
students did on that project--
I mean, maybe it was
great, maybe it wasn't.
But invariably,
those projects end up
having to focus so much on their
getting started documentation,
of making sure that they
have a clear guide for people
to get up and running in a
very short amount of time.
And those kinds of changes
really stick with the project
and just make the project
welcoming in general.
One of the things we
encourage a lot-- and this
is pretty common.
--is having a set of
issues on your project
that are specifically
labeled for beginners,
like beginner tasks that the
core team doesn't work on.
And they intentionally
don't work on it
so that when that newcomer
comes there's a really bite size
issue that they can fix.
And that really eases--
setting them up for success,
I think is really kind
of where I would say.
SARAH NOVOTNY: To
that point, you
can use those new contributors
to help with that onboarding
process, cause they get stuck.
You say, that's great.
Lets document this.
And then you work with them
to improve that process.
WILL NORRIS: One of the most
valuable perspectives I think,
is the person who doesn't know.
And it's so valuable because
you lose that perspective
so quickly.
And we find this
internally at Google
because Google is structured
so that you can move around
between teams very easily.
And so there's a
lot of mobility.
And when that new person
comes to your team,
you have to take
advantage of that time.
It's like you've got a very
short window before they start
learning all that
institutional knowledge that
never gets written down.
And so you've got
to write it down
when that person
is first coming on.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Kind
of piggybacking off of that.
I totally want to just point
out the cross-promotion of,
with other communities.
Right?
Because we've seen that on
a massive scale with Go,
in Kubernetes, in Docker.
I used to run a meet up
in San Francisco for Go.
And the amount of
evangelists, kind
of naturally coming to that
and doing speaking engagements,
really perpetuates that
level of like, ooh, this
sounds really awesome.
So five years ago,
I'm looking at, oh, I
heard that one meet up, that one
time, that one talk, and it's
exploded just because people
are willing to talk about it.
I also think-- of
off Will's point--
in a smaller project that I
worked on prior to Google,
labeling in GitHub was a huge
help for new contributors.
And then after-- since we've
talked about the getting
of the contributors-- after you
have a nice little, small pool,
we would do weekly
meetings with them
for like 30 minutes
just to encourage them
and to make them feel
like they were really part
of a collaborative process.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Which
ends up leading to making
the feeling of a tribe.
So you need to have some sort
of cohesive group feeling
in order to join
and participate.
And you have to
feel as if you're
making some sort of contribution
that is recognized and valued.
And every community needs to
have that space where you are
able to say, I participated.
I met the luminary who
wrote Go, the luminary who
started Kubernetes.
And then there's this
sense of togetherness.
You end up aligning a group of
people in a single direction.
And you can't understate
how valuable--
or you can't overstate
how valuable that is.
CHRIS DIBONA: So before I ask my
next broad question type thing,
we do have some microphones.
And in about 10 minutes, if
you want to ask, we'll see.
There's there and there.
So we say this word
community a lot.
It's kind of, in some ways,
the least defined thing ever.
And we say, open, a lot.
And I'm not going to say
it's frustrating for me
but I've always tried
to be really annoyingly
particular about this.
And so when you say
community, when you say,
open, and I think,
open source software
licensed under an
open sourced license
and offered to the public.
But what does it mean to you?
What is your gold standard of
how you like to best interact
technically in these projects?
So I just--
And I know this is partly
me projecting but--
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
If I'm looking at,
what does it take
to be open, then I'm
looking at transparency.
Do we know why decisions
are being made in a project?
Can we see clear paths?
Is documentation
transparent, easy to follow?
I'm looking at collaboration.
So, how easy is it to
contribute to the process?
Does it feel collaborative?
Are people interacting?
Are they meeting at conferences?
Are they interacting on
a slack or a channel?
And then I think, lastly,
it would be inclusivity,
making sure that
there's an openness
of all types of
opinions and needs,
and that they're
being listened to.
And that people
feel it's easy to,
again, just have access and
feel included in the process.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I think there's
another underpinning component
to all of those, which
is respect for all
the people participating.
And it goes back to Will's point
that that newcomer's view--
even if you don't see it and
it seems perfectly obvious how
you should get from A to C--
that newcomer's view is gold
because there is friction
there.
And that friction,
if it's not going
to be a contributor
who drops out,
it might be user who drops out.
And so you're decreasing
your adoption.
So you have this adoption curve,
or this contributor curve,
where it's like, everybody who
thinks the Kubernetes might
be awesome.
And then everybody who
has read CONTRIBUTING.md
and maybe got stymied by it.
And then suddenly
you've got a list
of people who did understand
what we were saying
because we actually
forgot to mention
that K8S means Kubernetes.
And then you've got
this group who's
bothered to stick around
long enough to actually go
through all these hurdles.
And so you've decreased
the number of people,
and the people that
you're engaging with,
a lot, if you're not respecting
that newcomer view, if you're
not respecting the challenges
and feedback that people
are bringing to you.
So that, to me, is one of
the core pieces of openness.
CHRIS DIBONA: Will--
SARAH NOVOTNY: Licenses.
Sorry.
WILL NORRIS: No, I would say--
maybe provide a slightly
different perspective,
which is, we've
often said at Google
that there's no one
way to do open source.
And I really do believe that.
And that's true in so
many different ways,
in terms of licenses, in
terms of governance models,
in terms of community
management styles.
And Google is big enough that--
Sarah was making
this point earlier--
that even within the eight or so
projects that they engage with,
there's a lot of variety.
Within the thousands of
projects that Google releases,
there is a huge
amount of variety.
And it really comes
back to, why did you
open-source it to begin with?
And it's going to be
different for every project.
And so that gold standard
really depends on,
what were the goals of
releasing that project
in the first place?
And that's going to guide how
you make a lot of decisions.
And that's something that
Sarah and I have been working
on together for a little
while is, helping provide
that guidance for teams at
Google to really think through,
why are they releasing
it as open source,
and then, let that
dictate how they answer
a lot of these other questions.
SARAH NOVOTNY: You also have
the spectrum between open source
software, to an
open source project,
to an open inclusive community,
which is even further.
So open source
software, I often define
as code that is
publicly available
and has a license that
the OSI has checkboxed,
said, this is an
open source license.
So that would be
open source software.
Doesn't mean you get
an opinion on it.
It doesn't mean you get
to contribute or change it
but it's open.
It's available.
It is-- you're free to use it.
You're free to look at it.
You're free to fork it.
You're free to change
it on your own.
But you may not be able to
modify the core software
as it stands.
But as you move toward, down the
progression and the continuum
toward project, it
becomes much more
about pulling together a
cohesive community that
is looking to solve a
larger problem than any one
perspective can
accurately scope.
Sort of the blind men trying
to describe an elephant.
Each different piece
of your community
comes to the project bringing
you a different perspective.
And this is one of the
things we saw in Kubernetes.
Google had a very opinionated
way of dealing with containers.
We built Bork.
We built Omega.
We knew Kubernetes
was going to be
a thing that the
world needed but we
needed more perspectives.
And so that had to
be an open community.
That is not every project.
And that is not every project
that is released by anyone.
It's not every project
released by Google.
Android, as an example,
has fewer people
contributing and
changing the way
the Android open source
project moves from outside
of Google than many--
than Kubernetes at this--
well, maybe not direct
numbers because of the years,
but there are different
amounts of influence
based on the strategic
goals of the project.
CHRIS DIBONA: So I
don't want to turn this
into my personal meeting
with my colleagues
but what's wrong with how
we release code from Google?
What would you want
to see different?
What's hard?
What problems have you
seen when releasing code
from the company?
Because I have people from other
big companies come to me all
the time and say, wow, you
released a lot of stuff
but you didn't release this one
thing I wanted you to release.
And I'm like, eh, you know.
So tell me how we could
be doing a better job
and how we could all
be doing a better job.
WILL NORRIS: I'd know the
answer to that one immediately.
And it really relates to what
we were just talking about,
that there is no one
way to do open-source.
We could absolutely do a better
job of setting expectations,
that when you find a random
project in one of our GitHub
orgs, or on googlesource.com,
or wherever you find a project,
is this a project that is being
used in production at Google?
Is this being
actively developed?
Is it looking for community?
Or is this just a project that
is intended to be consumed
but maybe not collaborated on?
And we can-- you can argue
on which one is better
and all of that but regardless
of any of that, just
setting the right
expectation is something
that we could absolutely
do a better job of.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
For the Go project,
we do have a really
collaborative-- we
want contributors, et cetera.
And so, some of the
things that we've learned
would be, ask for opinions
and contributions early on.
So if you are going
to release then--
sometimes we get feedback
from behind the doors,
so that when you do you get
a little bit less of a nudge
there.
But I think even more so,
it is that you need to--
exactly what you're
saying, Will-- it's
an iterative process,
usually, when you
have a collaborative project.
It's all iterative.
And so that's the one thing
we've learned is, be clear.
Yes, it may not be perfect
when it is first released
but it's all iterative.
And the reason we do
that is because we
want those contributions.
WILL NORRIS: And
just being honest
and transparent about where a
project is along that spectrum.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Yeah.
SARAH NOVOTNY: I'm willing
to go out on a limb
and say, I guarantee it won't be
perfect when it goes out first.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY:
No, it for sure won't.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
No, for sure.
SARAH NOVOTNY: But to
Will's point, making sure
that we are setting expectations
is important but also showing
growth paths, showing how
someone can contribute,
and how they can continue
to engage with the project,
showing where the
project needs are,
and making sure that when we
are engaging with the community,
that their feedback
is recognized,
even if it isn't followed.
CHRIS DIBONA: So should I
ask about contributor license
agreements and DCOs?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, how much
actual problems do you
see around the apparatus
of intellectual property
actually keeping you from
getting contributors and all
the rest.
Because this is something
we talk about quite a bit.
We are a big company.
So we care a lot about
where software comes from,
who's writing it, who owns that
intellectual property as it's
released, and we have to be
very, very careful about it
because we get sued a lot.
So I'd be really
interested in hearing
if you've seen a real
problem because of that or--
because--
WILL NORRIS: You
see it occasionally.
For the most part, the
biggest problems we see
are just weird edge cases
that our automated tooling
can't handle.
And so a fair amount of my
time, and my team's time,
is spent dealing with
those edge cases,
and walking people
through the process,
and figuring it all out.
We will occasionally
see someone who
just is adamant about not
wanting to sign a contributor
license agreement.
And in those cases,
we have to say,
I'm sorry this is just
something that we do require
for a variety of reasons.
And we've seen time
and time again,
where having that contributor
license agreement has saved us,
or has allowed us a
degree of flexibility.
For example, we relicensed
Angular a few years ago.
We originally released it
under the Apache 2 license.
The community-- the
JavaScript community
largely preferred MIT.
And so we talked about it
and we made that decision
to relicense the project
under MIT, at the community's
request.
This was something that was
only possible because we
had contributor license
agreements for all
of those contributors.
SARAH NOVOTNY: And I'll
play devil's advocate
because Kubernetes was
a challenge for this.
So Kubernetes went
out into the world
with a half dozen
corporate entities
really working
closely with Google.
So our 1.0 launch had all of
these corporate collaborators.
And that worked great because we
all understood how this worked.
We were all signing the Google
contributor license agreement.
It was all OK.
But the idea that Kubernetes
was to be industry changing
and actually move the way
we thought about portable
workloads in the cloud meant
that we needed more, and more,
and more companies-- especially
very large companies,
especially companies who may
or may not compete with Google
in different consumer areas
and business product areas--
means that it got to be
a lot more contentious.
So, I want to contribute
to your thing.
I want to help you
achieve your goals
but I can't sign your license.
And so we got stuck with a few
corporate contributors saying,
that's great but we can't.
And Kubernetes, because we
knew we wanted this-- again,
going back to, what
was the strategic goal?
Going back to what the
strategic goal was,
we wanted this to
change the industry.
And so we knew that to
do that we had to let
go of some of the control.
And that was the creation of the
Cloud Native Compute Foundation
at the Linux Foundation.
And that then allowed us to
take the same language we
use for the Google
Contributor License Agreement,
cross-out Google, say
Cloud Native Compute
Foundation in all the locations,
change the tooling so that it
was the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation License,
transfer all the licenses with
all the existing contributors.
And now those
companies that were not
happy about signing a Google
Contributor License Agreement
were perfectly content
to sign the same language
as long as that transfer of
IP went to the Cloud Native
Compute Foundation.
And that was a fine
solution for this.
A lot of younger projects,
more recent projects,
have focused on
DCOs and not CLAs--
Developer Certificates
of Origin,
instead of Contributor License
Agreements, or Corporate
Contributor License Agreements.
And that's not
something that Google
is comfortable with because
there's not a lot of case
law about it at this point.
And a lot of the case law is
being litigated right now.
And until there is a clear path.
Until there is a
clear way that you
can handle the, oops, we need
to relicense this, or oops,
we need to make a big
change without having
to contact the thousands
of contributors that
may have contributed
to a project,
until that case law exists,
it's too big of risk.
CHRIS DIBONA: Have you seen
any problems with this?
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Well,
Go sits a little differently
in the bucket than I think
everything else's projects do.
SARAH NOVOTNY: See, no one way.
CASSANDRA SALISBURY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We, being that we're a
programming language,
it is a little bit different.
But I can say that last
summer, before I joined Google,
I sat in a room--
Will, you alluded to this--
with a I think it was 150,
for our first ever contributor
workshop.
And it did require that everyone
go through the CLA process,
which was interesting together.
But it was also super
rad and I definitely
didn't have any
problems at my table.
And I don't believe
we had any problems
with that particular portion
of it at the other tables.
So--
CHRIS DIBONA:
Thank you for that.
SARAH NOVOTNY: Inside baseball.
CHRIS DIBONA: What's that?
SARAH NOVOTNY: It's
totally inside baseball.
CHRIS DIBONA: It is but I'm
the moderator, so whatever.
No, I mean that in a nice way.
So-- and we're out
of time, so I'm
going to say thank you
to all of you for coming.
And thank you to the panelists.
And have a great
rest of your I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]